[MUSIC PLAYING]
So now that we're all experts in
OAuth 2.0, we know that the
first thing we want to do
to sign the user in is
create a client ID.
So let's start doing that.
Now, if you've created any
client IDs before for any
other Google services in the
past, you know that the thing
to do is you go to
code.google.com/api/console,
and you create a new
project here.
Call it Screencast Example,
because I'm really creative.
And maybe we turn on
some services like
the Calendar API.
And we'll accept terms
of service.
And then we go to the API Access
section, and we create
an OAuth 2.0 client ID.
We'd add our product name,
My Calendar project.
And we might create one for a
web application where we would
create a client ID to find a
redirect URI or maybe an
installed application where you
could set up something for
an iOS device like this.
And look at that.
We got a client ID.
And everything is good, right?
Wrong.
This is not the way you would
set up a client ID
using the Games API.
So if you've been following
along with the last minute of
what I've been doing, stop and
erase everything you just did.
In fact, I'm going to go ahead
and delete this project.
Yes, I want to delete.
All right.
So let's close this window
here and start again.
The reason I'm not asking you
to go to that Google APIs
Console is that when you
create a game in Game
Services, you're enabling a
bunch of features such as
leaderboards and achievements.
And those need to be set
up and associated
with a client ID.
And so we're going to create
our OAuth 2.0 client ID
through the Google Play
Developer Console instead.
So let's look at that.
To get to the Google Play
Developer Console, you're
going to go to
play.google.com/apps/publish.
When we get there, you should
see a screen that maybe looks
a little something like this.
If you have never used the
Google Play Developer Console
before, you'll be prompted to
create an account, which is
something you are going
to have to do.
You do have to pay a one-time
fee of $25, and that's to, I
guess, queue out the spammers.
And no, there's no way
around it, even
if you're just testing.
So if that's you, go ahead and
pause this video, create an
account, and I'll see you back
here in a couple minutes.
OK.
Now that we all have accounts
set up on the Google Play
Developer Console, the thing
we're going to do is click on
this Use Google Play game
services button.
This takes us to the tab here
on the left with this little
controller icon.
And we're going to click on
this button to set up Play
game services on a new game.
So because this is a brand new
project, we are going to say,
we don't use any Google
APIs in our game yet.
This other tab, I already used
Google APIs in my game, would
be useful if, say, you had
created APIs in the past on
the Google APIs Console that
I showed you earlier.
Maybe you added maps to your
game or something.
And this would successfully
import that project and
associate that client ID with
whatever leaderboards and
achievements you create
in the future.
In our case, it's
much simpler.
We don't have any Google
APIs in our game yet.
And so we're just going to
create one from scratch.
So the name of our game I am
going to call "Guess My
Number." And we'll give
it a category.
I think this is really
Brain and Puzzle.
And you'll notice this fine
print underneath says, hey,
we're going to turn on Cloud
Save, Google+, Google Play
game services for you.
All those switches on the Google
APIs Console, we don't
need to do that.
So we'll just click Continue
and let it do its thing.
And now we're left with
our Game Details page.
This name and description will
inform how your game appears
throughout our system, including
on the Play Games
app that is available
on Android devices.
So make this somewhat
user friendly.
Maybe you could use
your Play Store
description here as well.
In our case, we're just going
to make something--
you know, actually, we can just
leave this blank because
we don't really care for
testing purposes.
The high-res icon, the feature
graphics, again, this is what
would appear throughout our
system, including the Play
Games destination app.
So you'll want to make sure that
you use a nice icon and
graphic here.
Again, for testing purposes,
we don't need any of this.
So I'm just going to click Save
and leave this blank.
The next thing we're going to
want to do is create a linked
application.
This panel here is where we
create our OAuth 2.0 client
IDs as well as associate them--
or I guess link them--
with any achievements and
leaderboards that we create in
the future.
Because we are creating an iOS
app, we're going to click this
Link an iOS app button.
And we've got the
name of our app.
We're going to say Yes to iPhone
and iPad here even
though our game is really only
optimized for the iPhone.
You really only set this to No
if you didn't want users
playing this particular game
on a particular device.
In our case, I'm happy to
have users playing games
on my iPad as well.
So I'm going to add our bundle
identifier, which would be
com.google.GuessMyNumber.
And I'm going to leave the
iTunes app ID blank for now.
Hit Save and Continue.
And we're going to get a button
saying, click this to
authorize your app now.
So I'm going to click
that button.
And this is branding
information.
You might ask yourself, hey,
wait a minute, I just added
branding information.
What is this stuff?
This is basically the name and
the logo that would appear in
that OAuth 2.0 dialog that pops
up when the user first
signs into your application.
So you'll want to make sure
it looks legitimate.
You want to make sure
your product name
says something real.
For a product logo, well, I'm
going to enter in a fantastic
Google logo.
In your case, you probably
want to add something
associated with your own product
or company and/or
homepage URL.
We'll do google.com.
On this section, you'll notice
your choices are very limited.
It's an installed application,
and it's iOS.
Confirm that this bundle
ID is correct.
It should be.
And if you have an App Store ID,
you can add it right here.
In our case, we can
leave it blank.
And we can hit Create Client.
And look at that.
We now have a client ID.
So now, if you remember back to
our presentation, remember
how we said that Google keeps
a database of client IDs and
authorized redirects.
Well, for our "Guess My Number"
game, we now have a
client ID, which we just got
back from the Google Play
Developer Console as well as an
authorized redirect, which
is based on the bundle
identifier that
we gave to the system.
So this com.google.Guess
MyNumber:/oauth2callback, that
is now associated with
our application.
And you'll see how we use
that very shortly.
So there we go.
We now have a client ID.
Keep a note of this.
Maybe copy and paste it into a
text file somewhere because
you're going to need this.
However, if you forget to and
you need it again at some
point, in your Linked Apps
listings, if you just click on
this, you'll see
it right here.
So you can always get to your
client ID if you ever need it.
By the way, let's look at
our other panels here.
You'll see Achievements.
This is where we'll be able to
set up achievements at some
point in the future.
Leaderboards, where we'll be
able to set up leaderboards.
And Testing, which is where we
can add test accounts that are
allowed to access these game
services before we publish.
Definitely go to the testing
panel if you haven't and
confirm that the account that
you're planning on testing
with is added here.
By default, it should add the
account that you're using to
develop with along with any
other accounts on your team,
unless they don't have a G+
account set up, in which case,
they won't get added.
But again, you might be using
a different account to test
with than the one you're
developing with.
And if that is the case, click
this Add Testers button, and
you can add, for example,
example@gmail.com.
That's probably not
a real address.
We won't actually add this.
But if you did add some
addresses, they would be
listed here as well.
By the way, you might also
notice that we've got some
green icons next to each
of our sections.
And they signify different
things.
If an icon is a half-green
circle like this, that
basically means that you've
provided enough information to
start testing the game but
not enough to have
published the game.
If you provide enough
information to publish this
particular section, it will have
a green check like this.
And if there's really a problem,
you'll see this grey
triangle icon.
So we can see here that
everything is set up enough
for us to at least test.
However, we're not allowed
to publish yet.
And if you click on this
section, you'll see that it
gives you a number of things
that are missing.
So we don't have an icon for
Game Details, we don't have an
iTunes app ID, and we need
to provide at least five
achievements for our game.
So we're good enough for
testing, not enough for
publishing.
But that's OK, because really,
testing is all we need for our
development purposes.
So now that we've gotten our
very first client ID, let's
make use of it and really
add that Sign In button.
And we're going to do that
in the next lesson.
[MUSIC PLAYING]